hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
and it has been said that while the 20th
century was the century of physics
the 21st century will belong to biology
i'm not sure if that's true or not i
think the 21st century is big enough to
have more than one science in it there's
plenty of room for
both physics and biology to do good
things but there's no question
that the rate of progress in biology has
been
pretty amazing in recent years and shows
no sign
of slowing down especially in our
ability to really manipulate what's
going on
down at the level of cells and even
individual strands of
dna those of you who are long-time
mindscape listeners will remember
a conversation we had with kate uttamala
who works on
synthetic life putting together cells
from scratch
right i mean we don't quite have that
done yet but this program
of building a cell starting with our
human knowledge rather than from
existing biology what we have done so
far
is taking existing organisms removing
their dna by an organism i mean a little
tiny
one-celled organism removing its dna and
inserting
dna that we have designed and seeing
whether or not it will keep going
so a few years ago scientists at the
ventner institute named after craig
ventner
were able to build what is essentially
we think the minimal
cell that actually works in some sense
that actually reproduces
itself and so forth but to be honest it
didn't reproduce itself that well
you know like we hope that an individual
cell will split into
so that both halves look more or less
like the original cell
that's not happening with these minimal
cells so today's guest is elizabeth
strzhalski
who works as the group leader of the
cellular engineering group
at nist the national institute of
standards and technology
and so she and her collaborators
including many of the people on the
previous
program were able to fix the
minimal cell to build a minimal cell
that reproduces
nicely in some way so basically they
took
genes and they reinserted them back into
the dna
until this little one cell bugger was
able to reproduce
nicely splitting into equal sizes
perfectly healthy
single-celled organisms what's amazing
is all
it's amazing number one that we can do
that right i mean this is opening up
tremendous vistas for future progress
the fact that we can do it
means that someday we'll be able to do
it well and easily
but also number two we don't know what
all the individual genes
do what their responsibilities are in
the cell we know that if they're not
there it doesn't work
but we don't know what actually happens
in terms of those genes turning into
proteins and making the cell go
so it is an amazing frontier where we're
making progress but there's so many
things we don't know
so elizabeth and i talk about how this
stuff works
why you're looking for the minimal cell
at all how it actually
happens in the lab with designing the
dna and so forth
and then you know we speculate a little
bit about what this means about
the origin of life the fact that the
minimal cell has
quite a few genes in it hundreds of
genes
makes an interesting question arise
right i mean how did that come
about out of something that wasn't a
cell at all
uh but even more importantly perhaps for
practical purposes
what is this kind of technology going to
be good for in medicine
in drug design in sensing what is
happening in the body this is one of
elizabeth's specialties is
imagining that we can figure out how
your body is doing
by inserting little sensors into it that
we've constructed
synthetically as cells in their own
right so
i don't know what to say about this i'm
not a biologist uh but it's
extraordinarily exciting and
uh the the prospects are practically
limitless and i think that you know
in the decades to come we're going to be
seeing the payoff from this kind of
research and it's going to change
lots of things in interesting ways so
let's go
elizabeth strahalski welcome to the
windscape podcast thanks so much it's a
pleasure to be here
so as a physicist what what we're
trained to do what i'm trained to do
uh is tear things apart right to their
constituent pieces
whether it's an atom or a solar system
or something like that and look for the
basic underlying laws
and i know that a lot of people in
biology or at least i get the impression
that there's a conventional wisdom that
there are no such underlying laws in
biology biology is just a mess
every organism is different you have to
go piece by piece
so is that the right impression to have
or is the search for fundamental
underlying laws
still a good thing that we should try to
do personally i think that
even if there are no fundamental laws
that look like the fundamental laws we
might use
to use the finding even the search
itself is worthwhile
um there's nothing wrong with trying to
strip something to its essential
elements
to try to ask you know is is there an
essence there
um or how much of this object that i
understand
or want to be essential in some way is
actually the result of relationships
between the different parts
and do you find in your is going to peek
ahead a little bit but do you find in
your work that that's true
are we are we like discovering little
ideas that might someday grow
up into laws of biology wow
such a great question um it is my
sincere hope
that we find laws and uh
personally i'm hoping that we find laws
that look more like like
quantum mechanics in the wild right or
applied quantum mechanics where
we arrive at a recipe book that allows
us to do
practical things and so maybe biology
would look less like synthetic biology
more like engineering biology and again
you know these are words
but words matter it matters what you
call things
um and so you know we have some real
challenges in the world right now
that we face and i think we need to
bring
all of our collective knowledge and
capability to bear on these and one
exciting
tool set that we have is synthetic
biology and engineering biology
right well in fact the words that you're
using are
reminiscent of the metaphor i was going
to ask about i mean
in some sense what you do is kind of
like the enthusiasts for the latest
smartphone who tear them apart
when they appear and try to figure out
what all the pieces are right like
we have some working gizmo but in your
case it's a cell or an organism and
you're trying to tear it apart
right i love that analogy um and
i came originally so as a physicist i
grew up through the experimental high
energy
physics community and so what a lot of
what high-end physicists
try to do is to smash apart the basic
building blocks of matter to understand
what is there
and so for me it makes perfect sense
that you want to smash apart
a biological system to understand what's
there and how those
parts interact now of course
once you arrive at those laundry lists
of parts and relationships
there's still some secret sauce that we
don't understand
this science around emergence
complex systems and you know what's that
spark of life
that you know suddenly you no longer
have just
a pile of stuff you have a pile of stuff
that is air quotes here you know alive
right well i mean i actually
your statement makes me realize there's
something very
fundamental and simple that i don't
understand i understand when
a person dies uh or uh
any higher organism dies there's a whole
bunch of processes that go on between
the cells
uh that no longer happen so we don't
it's a it's
very similar set of atoms and molecules
but it's no longer a living being
what happens when a cell dies do cells
die do they just you know sort of grow
old um yeah so some cells die
some cells grow old in certain ways um
i should mention as an aside that i am
emphatically not a cell biologist
i nearly play one on tv right
um uh it's always good to have a cell
biologist
um on your team when you're working in
this video and i should mention
too that what's really exciting about
the way biology is moving forward
um around questions of you know minimal
life
um synthetic cells is you find yourself
on these larger collaborations where you
need
deep knowledge in lots of different
fields all coming together and the
interstices of those fields
to make it happen so i bring the physics
and engineering perspective
um but coming back to your question
about actually cells
sorry you've opened up a little
pandora's box there i gotta i gotta dig
into this more
so you and your team and the your
collaboration that you're working with
are
literally building cells so to someone
like me that makes you a cell biologist
so
i mean maybe what is
how do you classify yourself what are
the different kinds of people who have
to work together to make something like
this happen
one of the really exciting things about
working in the life sciences right now
and specifically in synthetic biology
and engineering biology some people call
it cellular engineering i want to make
sure that i say a lot of the different
buzzwords so that folks can go google
these later if they want to learn more
um it's it's that we're
taking these well-developed deep
uh bodies of knowledge from what used to
be
silo disciplines and we're basically
mashing them all together to see what
sticks
so for example you mentioned control of
biology earlier
so if i take control engineering as we
understand it
from say radios and computers or
building a car
and then overlay that with cell biology
what might be possible right and this is
one thing
that folks are trying to understand
right now so typically
you know you might have somebody who has
biophysics knowledge you need people who
have knowledge of the different
measurement techniques that you need for
example maybe
uh you know electron microscopy or
fluorescence microscopy
or dna sequencing
you might need an automation specialist
because
as we know biology labs are looking less
and less like
someone standing next to a bench with a
pipettor in their hand and a white coat
hopefully he goggles too as well please
everybody to the extent that you're in
your garage
biohacking please take safety seriously
we're the goggles yes
and it's starting to look more and more
like uh
laboratories filled with robots
so you might have we have a mechanical
engineer who's part of our team
in my laboratory for example we work
with
folks who are experts in machine
learning because
as you automate these measurements and
these experiments
you get a whole lot of data out more
than
it's easy even to think about it's a lot
um and what that does is it lets you ask
new and different kinds of questions
about biology because you can bring to
bear
all of this incredible computation power
um that you get from machine learning
okay so i interrupted you and you were
explaining how cells can die
what i mean what is the process inside
that no longer happens
to that collection of atoms and
molecules well
the easiest thing to say i think is that
it's no longer
doing the things a living cell does
and i know you've had other guests on
your show who have spent
time talking about what is life or
um even about building synthetic cells
um i think for me as somebody who comes
from more of a physics and engineering
standpoint
i like to think of life and death as
kind of the spectrum
okay in the same way that i think of a
spectrum from chemistry to biology
and depending on what you want to build
or
do what capability you want to have you
might want to situate yourself
at different places on those spectrum so
for example
i might want to bio remediate something
which would mean that i'm going to
engineer something biological
and then release it well do i really
want it to be able to reproduce
right maybe not right
i've seen that movie it doesn't go well
no you know it never does
it never does and um
i a couple years ago i was actually
trying to convince some
funders that we need to um
try out uh terraforming technologies on
an asteroid or something
offer because that way when we need it
here it's not our first go
right right right yeah well okay
so so that is very interesting i think
like you said we've had people on the
show
who've talked about what is life what is
a cell kate uttamala who i guess is a
collaborator of yours
or at least in the same big group uh
talked a little bit about synthetic
biology but
maybe some of the people listening right
now haven't even heard that and so what
i'm guessing is
everyone knows that cells have membranes
and little nucleus inside with dna
and the dna converts its little parts
into proteins which then go do things
uh do we need more knowledge than that
for what's about to come when we talk
about building a
synthetic cell i mean what about how the
cell works is is the basic knowledge
platform that we're gonna have to build
on here there's so much
fundamental knowledge we still need to
gain and
um just to make sure you know for
completeness that we cover this
there are sort of two main
paths forward that people are walking
down to arrive at something like
a a synthetic cell or a minimal cell
so you can take the bottom-up approach
where you take non-living parts
if you're a purist i guess you would
start with chemistry not even
biochemistry
and you would try to assemble bits and
pieces
until life happens so
this has not been done yet to the best
of my knowledge okay
um and although lots of folks
are working in this area and making
great progress
the other path forward is more of a
top-down approach
where you start with something that is
already a living cell
and you take parts out until
it dies in some way now it's
really simple to say these things but
when you actually go about trying to do
them
you know uh the devil's in the details
and with regard to the minimal cell work
that um i've been doing recently with
just wonderful collaborators at the j
craig mentor institute and in other
places
and i want to give a shout out to my
co-authors james palutear and luigi sun
they're just fantastic to work with um
so what we've been doing there is
uh you start with something called an
obligate parasite
okay and what that means is it's an
organism that can't live
outside of its host it still has all the
cellular machinery that it needs
but it's adapted to live in a very
stable very specialized environment
which means that it hasn't needed to
retain
a lot of the genetic information or
proteins or other bits of itself
that it needs to respond to a changing
environment but this is one
one cell we're talking about a
unicellular organism that's right
that's right this is a kind of
mycoplasma okay
um and it's a goat tuberculosis i guess
so i had to sign up outside my lab for a
long time saying
you know if you have a pet goat
um so uh
these scientists developed a way to
scramble parts of the genome
and then grow the cells that resulted
and then you can sequence the dna
that's left of this from the cells that
grew well
so you can guess that you know if any of
the genes were scrambled
and so couldn't be expressed they must
not be essential for life
so cut them out um so you can take that
empirical approach you can also
take an approach where you look at
related organisms and
and you can kind of guess what the
function of different genes might be
and guess whether or not a certain gene
is essential or not
now you'll notice i'm not saying
essential for what
because when folks talk about
minimal life or minimal cells what's
implicit in that is that you're
minimizing to some
criteria you're putting some boundary
conditions on this thing
and when um the jcbi and collaborators
published in 2016
um the minimal cell this was jcbi synth
3.0
what they did was they minimized the
criteria of
the cell growth looks normal at the
colony level
so when you looked and you could even
see these by eye
you've got this beautiful you know if
you've ever seen a mycoplasma colony it
looks a little bit like a fried egg and
i probably never have
and so it looked totally normal and the
other thing that they wanted
was they wanted the cells to grow
fast enough again air quotes here that
it was useful
for work in the laboratory nobody wants
to sit around for a week while their
cells finally get around to double
right um it's just not practical really
slow down your research so they wanted
to keep genes that would keep the cells
growing
fast enough to be useful okay well we
took a closer look at what was happening
it turned out that none of these
minimization criteria
paid any attention to what was happening
at the single cell
level and so when we looked under our
microscope
it was absolutely bonkers what was going
on
i mean crazy we took some
optical micrographs that showed videos
of these things growing in microfluidic
chips on our microscope
and you would start with this perfect
you know spherical round totally normal
looking cell
and then you come back a little while
later and there are filamentous cells
branching cells huge things that
i don't even know if it's a cell or a
huge vesicle um
and it's just crazy because we
we if we try to understand biochemically
what's inside of these structures what's
stabilizing them what about
the biophysics of the membrane for
example leads to these
uh we don't actually know and all of
this is happening in the background of
us not even
understanding what the division
mechanism is for these cells
whenever i'm reading outside my own
areas of expertise
it's very helpful to have some expert
guidance like a good book club
curated by someone who knows what
they're talking about literati
book clubs provide exactly that they
have 12 unique book clubs
curated by people from stephen curry to
malala to richard branson
i personally am involved in the joseph
campbell book club now joseph campbell
admittedly not with us anymore but the
joseph campbell foundation
picks a bunch of books in the general
areas of myths and the universal human
experience
and then gives you one book a month so
you can read along
the curators will host exclusive
interviews with the authors themselves
where you can ask your biggest questions
and get the insider answers you won't
find from any other book club
and all book club members can shop the
entire literati library
at discounts that are so deep they look
like cliffhangers with many books over
50
off so reimagine what a book club can be
redeem your
30-day trial for only 99 cents at
literati.com
mindscape so head to literary.com
mindscape to learn more
and read more with literati that's l i t
e r a t i dot com slash mindscape
so your task was to fix the
cell so the vendor institute had
stripped away parts
from a mycoplasm and uh
made a sort of minimal self-reproducing
cell
um but it didn't reproduce very prettily
and you wanted to sort of
give it a little bit more uh uh
coherence somehow is that fair
i think that's that's fair and um it's a
microplasma
and uh so you may or may not care for
your purpose
whether the cell looks pretty at the
single cell level you know
your your end goal might only
want a pretty minimal cell that
gives you this this normal-looking
colony um
but if you're talking about cellular
engineering you know
and you're talking about inserting new
functions
inserting new genes like understanding
there are folks who are working on
wholesale models of these cells
to try to really drill down and
understand well what
is each molecule doing what is each
gene product from each gene doing so we
can draw direct lines from genotype to
phenotype
that is to say from the dna the genotype
to the
actual organism the phenotype that's
right
and so you know as an engineering tool
you know cell size and shape is it's one
of the most
basic aspects of cellular
life like maybe we should understand
this guys
um and so you know jcpi had had declared
victory and in many ways um it was a
great victory they developed a lot of
impressive techniques that have pushed
the field forward
um but i i thought it was really
important and i'm glad they thought so
also
to take a closer look at division in
these cells and trying to understand
these different
phenotypes these different more
followers use the sizes and shapes
let me actually back up because i think
there's probably a lot of details here
that would be fascinating to the
audience i mean
uh when you say that you take the
dna in one of these cells and you chop
it up and you you turn off or or
scramble
some genes number one how do you do that
it's not i i think that probably a lot
of people have in mind that you know
you have tweezers and you stretch out
the dna and then you like
chop off your finger
i mean these are very tiny molecules
these dnas
this is a great point and um you know
again as a physicist
and i have a great interest in
mechanical systems
um you know i love thinking of of
tweezers but in this case the tweezers
are um
well this is what makes uh ligie's work
in particular so heroic
and the other scientists at jcdi because
they're the ones who
really develop the capability to reach
into this minimal cell and um
genetically
modify it so um what you can do
is so first of all i should let's let's
back up a little bit here yeah please
so the the minimal cell i
mentioned it was called jcpisin 3.0 well
there was a 1.0
and 1.0 involved printing dna
on a machine so this dna had never been
in a living organism
and then what you do is you
you take a cell
make its dna such that it's no longer
expressible so essentially you have a
zombie cell now you kind of take out its
brain
cell and then you take your printed
synthetic
dna this synthetic genome
and you kind of well we don't know
exactly how the genome transplantation
process works
this is something that's still an open
question okay
but it does work um the yield isn't
great
um so if this is something that
personally i would like to work on more
to understand because i think
if we could print just as an aside uh if
we could print
any dna we wanted and insert it into any
cell whose genome we've you know
inactivated
think of what would be possible because
you wouldn't have to go through any
living intermediates
right you wouldn't have to make these
kind of adiabatic you know incremental
changes
to your cell to arrive at what you want
you could just
you could just print it 3d print yours
blows my mind life
yeah anyway but we can't but we almost
can
there's like some sort of uh hacky way
of doing it probabilistically or
something
what did they do so um
we tried to do it in microfluidics but
the yield was too low for us to see what
was happening um
but they think that part of the secret
sauce is that
you have your cells growing up in a
fluid in there
basically in the broth that they grow in
and then you
add a polymer um
peg polyethylene glycol of a certain
molecular weight at a certain time in
the growth at a certain temperature and
the moon is in the right phase
and you know you've got the person doing
you as the magic hands
um and by the way magic hands are
actually a broader issue
with regard to reproducibility yeah sure
the biosciences so
so it's a thing um and
um what happens is the peg makes cells
kind of slam together
so so they slam together with this dna
that you want inside of them
we think there's something like a big
sensational cell that forms
and then at their next growth cycle they
kind of divide apart
and um so a sensational cell is one
where it has multiple genomes inside of
it
so think of all of these cells forming
one big membrane
together and then when they grow apart
again some will have
the new genome that you've printed
that's synthetic
some might have the old and activated
genome but at any rate once you grow
them up you now have
your zombie cells come back to life with
the new genomes
and um part of the process of putting
together these synthetic genomes
was that um dan gibson and folks
divided that genome up into different
pieces
and because it's hard to manipulate a
whole genome at once
if you think of like imagine a really
really long
piece of cooked spaghetti i mean really
long you know and if you wanted to pick
it up and move it somewhere
chances are it's going to come apart in
your hands you might get some breaks or
you might
nick it somewhere right and all of that
would mean if it were a genome that it's
not going to express
in the way that you want anymore um so
they were able to manipulate
this genome in yeast using very
interesting techniques that i don't
fully understand
but i'm thankful that they did and one
of the reasons i'm thankful is that one
of those
segments we call this segment six ended
up having
um so first of all these segments gave
us handles for looking at the gene
content in each of these segments
to try to understand well does this
segment have the genes that affect
shape and size of the minimal cell
so one of these segments segment six
actually
you know so it did seem to have these
genes
and so what we could do then is narrow
down our search to a much smaller number
of genes
um and uh then through a much
more systematic approach
you know testing groups of genes and
then single genes
we drill down on seven genes that seem
to together
re-uh constitute control of cell size
and shape in the minimal cell
so now there's this jcbi icing 3a strain
that um i think something like 43
different labs are using around the
world
to study the minimal cell so we call it
a nearly minimal cell
because it does have more genes than sin
3.0
um but what you get in return is that
you have cells that are
much better behaved at the single cell
level so you had
what was judged to be the minimal cell
then you added in seven more genes
and that helped it reproduce in a
aesthetically pleasing way
and you know the real kicker is here too
that
um so those seven genes
included two genes that are known to be
involved in cell division
ftsc and stefan but the next one
is is a hydrolase with some unknown
substrate
and then four of the genes we have no
idea what they do
we think that they might encode
membrane-associated proteins
but we have no idea what they're doing
so even in this most
basic aspect of cell physiology
um we run across these genes of unknown
function
and um they are really an elephant in
the room when you talk about these whole
cell models people are trying to build
or cellular engineering or synthetic
biology in general there's so much of
the genome
that we aren't able to tie back to some
function
so you but you do you have convinced
yourselves that if you didn't include
every one of these seven genes it
wouldn't do what you wanted to do so
you're not sure why
but you need all seven of these genes
that's right
and um one thing we haven't mentioned is
that this is an absolute tour divorce
um this reverse genetics approach that
we took
um i think since i got involved in the
project i think it was seven years
until we published which is long even
for biology
it's short for particle physics as you
know so um
but okay i mean so i'm going to ask the
even dumber question that i ask for
every
cellular molecular bio type person i
have on the podcast
what do you mean when you say a gene
like i know what a base pair is
in dna um i have this vague feeling that
a d
a gene is a group of base pairs that
does a thing
but like how do you operationally pick
out which part of the
dna strand is the beginning of the gene
and then the end of the gene like who
says how do you figure that out
chris this is a fantastic question and
personally i rely on the experts in this
area
this is not my area of expertise but
there are
databases you can go look at where
people kind of
parse genomes and
uh you know it's not all settled also
you know
people might say that well you've got to
group these together you know these base
pairs together
in order to form a a gene that makes
some
protein and then somebody might come on
say actually you've got to shift it a
little bit this way or that way
um that makes me feel better because i
didn't understand it so if it's not
understood then i feel like less
less behind the curve a little bit i'm
uh
i defer to the experts right okay very
good
and i should i probably should footnote
something because i think i mentioned
the nucleus of a cell at the beginning
but of course these are probably going
to be
prokaryotic cells there's no nuclei in
them right
that's right and um i think that one of
uh it would be a really interesting
capability to take this
genome minimization process that's been
demonstrated for
this very simple obligate parasite this
mycoplasma
and apply it to a eukaryote
so a cell that does have a nucleus maybe
a yeast or maybe a mammalian cell
uh and you know see what we learned from
that
okay because this minimal cell it isn't
just a thing right it's not just jcd ice
and 3a and we're done
it's also a whole repertoire of
tools and tricks and measurements that
we can apply to any number of biological
systems
and how many genes total in this minimal
cell
so jcvisin3a has 493
protein encoding and just uh for
reference
and e coli has about 4400 genes
and humans have about 20 000 although i
think that's
uh we're still sorting that out exactly
but then there are other they're like
dandelions or whatever they have way
more than human beings right like human
beings are not the maximum number of
genes or anything close
no but you know it's a natural point of
reference for us sure oh yes absolutely
but
i don't want to put us up too much on
our high horses we're not the we're not
the most numbered we're actually kind of
more efficient in some ways right than
uh
than some organisms well i i appreciate
your comments
um but i actually do want to put us on
our high horses for a second here
sure because um when i was talking about
the genome minimization process i
mentioned that there were these sort of
arbitrary criteria that you're
minimizing
with respect to and one thing that i
find so fascinating about
the creation of you know proto-life
synthetic cells
minimal cells is how much of the
scientist
um just unavoidably ends up in that
process
and in that product right it's it's
almost like
um it's it's an art form in some ways
or a mirror where we're using this new
medium
of synthetic biology or engineered
biological systems to hold a mirror up
to ourselves
and i'm hoping that because there's sort
of two ways to get past the n equals one
problem
of of um biological systems so
uh just to back up here a second one of
the challenges
of creating synthetic life is that when
we look around us
we really only have one example of
cellular life
and that's what's involved here on earth
so there are two ways
i think that two main ways where we
could get more examples one would be to
go out and find it somewhere else
hopefully we'll recognize it the other
way is for us to build it
um i'm hoping that we're not so biased
by
ourselves and ourselves
that we aren't able to imagine what else
could be possible and this also brings
me back then to your question about
the rules of life and what are they
and i think so much is unknown here that
as we go about engineering biological
systems it's almost as if
um you know we're not limited by
by you know the the fundamental physics
of it right
the laws of the universe of it at this
point
it's almost like we're limited by our
imaginations
the minimal cell that that you mentioned
with almost 500 genes
um i presume that once again we have a
high degree of confidence that if we
removed
any one of them it wouldn't work anymore
right that's what it means to be minimal
that's right and i should note that
there are about 100 genes of unknown
function
left in that cell so we don't know what
they do but we know that if we didn't
have them
things would go wrong that's right um
there are also those some subtleties in
this too so imagine if you have an
airplane
and you want to take parts off that
airplane until it's not able to fly
anymore
so let's say that i remove an engine
but you know i'm gonna say that's not
essential because i've got another
engine
right but what if i remove both engines
right
so so the way the process is sort of
path dependent
right so it matters how you get there to
the minimal cell
and you can find yourself accidentally
deleting genes that were essential
like we did when we developed 3.0 and we
needed to
put genes back in to get control of cell
size and shape
and even though uh the actual dna
was synthesized if i understand it
correctly um
it was all based on real genes that
appeared in living organisms no one
is yet going in and building base pair
by base
pair new functional genes is that right
wow that would be incredible if we could
do that but we are not there yet
okay um but you know this point that
there are a number of challenges still
and
for minimal cells i think that we need
to know what these we need to learn what
these genes of unknown function are
doing
um i think that we need to arrive at a
more genetically
tractable minimal cell what i mean by
that is that we have tools where
not just you know the properly
indoctrinated
and practiced folks at jcdi but
anyone is able to very easily
genetically modify
these cells so right now they put
something called landing pads into the
genome
okay where um you can add genes easily
at those places um so
that does help a lot but for right now
if you want to
delete genes um you have to go through
this
docking genome and yeast manipulating it
there and then
do this genome transplantation process
to arrive at
the modified genome now for right now
um there aren't so many people working
with this cell
that um jcbi won't
you know generously offer to help you
with this
but at a certain point i think our hope
is that um
more folks will take up this system um
so that because there's there's so much
to learn and there's so much to know
clearly yeah um other other challenges
for the minimal cell
is um how do we generalize that
minimization workflow for other
organisms
and then what is close to my heart
because i
i work at the national institute of
standards of technology
so i'm a metrologist i study the science
of measurements
i would like it if we could make it
easier to measure
the current minimal cell so this thing
is really small
it's about the same size as the
wavelength of light
so it's really hard to see and
um so i was talking with my
collaborators and i said well
can we just make this thing bigger yeah
like if we really can
just engineer the size and shape can we
just make it bigger well maybe
um are there techniques to swell the
cell or
um yeah so if if
this set of genes is needed we think
minimally at least
it is let's say a minimal set right like
if we removed anything from that set
like you say it wouldn't work anymore
but maybe there's another set
that is containing different genes that
is also has the
feature that if you removed anything it
wouldn't work either right i mean maybe
there's more than one way to be minimal
that's so important and i'm so glad you
brought that up
because and this is why i want to focus
on that workflow of minimization because
i think at the end of the day
can i say this i don't want to get into
much trouble but
microplasma is not that useful for
people
yeah it's good as a research platform
um but it's it's not that useful and so
if we can empower people to make minimal
versions
of their own cells of interest minimized
according
to their own criteria imagine what we
could learn
i i think it would be really empowering
and even if this particular species
is like you say not that useful uh can
we nevertheless relate
this set of genes the 400 and some genes
in this cell
are these same genes elsewhere do they
also exist in other kinds of cells so we
feel like this is an instruction set
that is common to all kinds of life or
is it not
that's true for a lot of the genes that
are in the cell
and this is a common technique that cell
biologists use where they
look at related organisms or even not so
related organisms and try to guess what
the function
of different genes or proteins is
um and this is
this is one of the reasons why it's a
little vexing that we still don't
understand
the mechanism behind cell division in
these cells
because we we can't point to a mechanism
from
so far from another cell and say oh our
mycoplasma
is dividing like that other cell
um but you know one reason why
mycoplasma was
chosen is that it comes pre-minimized by
nature
as an obligate parasite so it's been
kind of singled out for a while as a
candidate
hydrogen atom of biology
um and i want to mention too that this
idea of a minimal cell is really not new
i mean way back in ancient times you
know philosophers love to think about
the building blocks of
matter including life but more recently
in the 20th century i believe in the
1930s a bunch of scientists got together
physicists were involved i think even in
the leadership role
and they decided that a minimal cell
could exist
and you know what maybe it ought to
exist so
because it can do three things for us
and it still can do three things for us
it can tell us maybe how cellular life
came to be
maybe we can learn something about the
history of life it might offer a
platform for understanding
life today so for understanding the
present
cellular life including ourselves
and um more recently especially with the
work that i've become involved in i
think that it can offer a platform for
the future or what life could be
um and more specifically you know
what could we engineer cellular life to
be
we're at this really exciting time where
we have the
ability to hopefully soon make
a lineage agnostic life and this is a
term that i'm stealing from drew envy at
stanford
okay i heard him use this term and it
was just
such an eye opener for me because up
until now
every cell has come from another cell
but now that doesn't need to be the case
anymore
right so what does that mean what do we
do with that how do we understand that
i mean you actually raise a challenge
that i hadn't
quite appreciated before about the
origin of life
which you mentioned something that we
can try to learn something about if the
minimal cell has almost 500 genes
and genes have lots of base pairs in
them that sounds like
there's quite a gap to be bridged from a
bunch of uh
macromolecules to a living functioning
cellular organism yeah
it's it's going to be a while yet i
think and so stay tuned you know
hopefully in our lifetimes we'll we'll
get there and
this gap is one that we're trying to
close from both ends right we're using
this
bottom-up approach and this top-down
approach and
um the challenge that the bottom-up
folks have
um i know i shouldn't be favorites maybe
i am here a little bit but the bottom-up
folks
they there hasn't been success yet and
so it's very difficult to
focus their efforts um
whereas if we start from something
that's already alive
we're good at killing things yeah
or even injuring them yes
one way forward i think in the top down
approach
is to use those capabilities of
automation in the laboratory
machine learning to make lots of
different versions
of the genomically minimal cell
and then put them in lots of different
environments because
they're minimized in a specific
environment right we can't separate
those two
right in the same way that you know
we're nice and alive in our offices
right now breathing the air around us
you take that away and um you know
you might say well maybe they're missing
the gene that they need well but really
you just needed something in your
environment
right but if we can um if we can
you know massively parallelize um
and automate this process of
minimization
maybe that's a path forward for learning
new and interesting things
uh without the minimal cell maybe that
addresses what i was going to ask next
which is
if we have this minimal cell with 400
some genes
and as you've very provocatively
emphasized
we don't know what some of them do um
how do we how are we going to learn that
is it just a matter of like taking
one by one and seeing what fails or
because they do
interact with each other in in such
crucial ways do we need to be more
subtle than that
you know up until now learning the
function of each gene it's really been
hard one
and i've experienced that personally
with these seven genes that we've
identified in the minimal cell over i
even made a t-shirt that said seven
genes seven years
all right you need to speed things up a
little bit i guess
you know what we really do and now that
we've gone through this process
once um there are all kinds of things
that we would do to speed it up
use automation use proper design of
experiments
so for you biologists out there or other
folks who
don't know that this is a thing please
know this is a thing
where you can more efficiently design
your experiments to
get better answers out of a fewer number
of trials
we can do that we can work with our
machine learning colleagues to interpret
the data
um because numbers are great but if you
can't
get any meaning from them you know what
are they worth
yeah and i mean this might be jumping
outside of what we've been talking about
but
there's the issue of how the genes come
together to make a reproducing cell but
there's also
in bigger organisms the issue of how
cells come together to make an organism
and you know cells differentiate in
interesting ways
are there is there a parallel track
where we get to learn
about how cells interact to make like
morphology and things like that
uh based on what genes they have so even
just last week i was at a conference
with those folks so it's there's this
whole ecosystem
of different groups of researchers and
you know i have spent some time
uh having interesting conversations and
interactions with the build-a-cell folks
and the minimal cell phones
and the synthetic cell phones um but
then
there's also the tissue engineering
folks who interface with the
you know stem cell differentiation folks
and the organoid folks
and the soft robotics folks and you know
you can kind of
step your way through all of these
adjacent related very interesting fields
and it's just the most fun you can have
and i'm hoping we can all learn from
each other because you're absolutely
right
at the end of the day wouldn't it be
fantastic if we could build capabilities
not just at the cellular
level but also at the multi-cellular
level
so that we can engineer life at all
scales
um and uh
you know even extend it a little bit
further to become much better at
interfacing biotic and abiotic systems
so i i glean from your answer that even
though this would be very very exciting
and we should try to do it we don't know
that much
yet we did have michael levin on the
podcast from tufts and he talked a
little bit about
how organisms seem to have some kind of
memory of what their shape was supposed
to be like if you move the eye of
something it'll it'll move back
and and so forth but roughly speaking i
get the impression this is all kind of
mysterious
we don't know even if we don't know how
a specific cell
regenerates happily then knowing how a
macroscopic organism is going to do that
it's going to be much harder
challenge how wonderful that there are
these interesting questions
for us to investigate
you know i'm there's fantastic progress
in all of these areas
um again i'm not the best person
to speak to them um
i i guess i'll just put an advertisement
for uh you know
the life of a scientist here and just
invite anybody
just warmly please come investigate
these with us
good um it's a wonderful community and
everybody's ways of thinking about
different ideas
and approaching the problems they all
bring a unique perspective
and um you know clearly the way we've
been thinking about it so far
with the information we have we're not
there yet and so
maybe you can come and bring your ideas
and uh you know lead us all to the aha
moment
good so let's get back to the cell uh or
the individual cells so
uh you've hinted at the idea that uh one
of the motivations for building this
minimal cell
is that we can then de-minimalize it we
can sort of do
things with it you know we can start
adding things uh that we wanted to do so
what are your favorite potential
applications and we you know we can be a
little speculative here like this is not
a grant proposal review
we're thinking about what the future
might hold this is a great time for me
to put in the
obligatory nist disclaimer so nothing i
say here represents an official position
of the us government or implies
endorsement
of any company commercial product or
service
very good um so in some ways
what we're talking about here is and i'm
going to use this term
on purpose even though it is provocative
this idea of gain of function okay so
in some ways you could so typically
people use that term around infectious
disease research
but if you take it literally gain a
function
is engineering biology and if you talk
about building a minimal cell or life
from scratch that's almost the ultimate
gain of function research so i'm
imagining
that we learn enough and maybe the
minimal cell gives us a path forward for
this
where we can build up best practices
maybe some rules design rules rules of
thumb
um protocols where for different classes
of function
we understand how to put those back into
the cell
um which functions play nicely together
and which don't
right how do we manage resource
utilization in the cell
um and all of these bring us back to
that idea of
control in biology and
um you know i've been using the term
engineering biology in cellular
engineering
but unless and until we have a rigorous
control engineering for biological
systems
it's kind of an aspirational title okay
to say that it's engineering
um and so one thing that my lab works on
is
building sensors so if you imagine a
controller
let's say you know one that you might be
familiar with from
the cruise control in your car or the
thermostat in your house
what you have is um you have some
some desired output of a system
and there's a controller then that
controller might
do something to actuate some change in
the system
that leads to some output well if you
can close that loop
with a sensor with something that
measures
that output you can then feed that error
back in
to the controller to make sure that
you know you stay at your desired output
right so
what my lab does is it uses biological
parts
to make living measurement systems or
sensors
inside of cells because biology is
measuring itself all the time
seems like we ought to be able to make
measurement tools out of biology also
okay so you
when you started talking about that uh
with a thermometer or sorry the
thermostat analogy um i was going to ask
you know well so why have biological
sensors if we have perfectly good
physical ones but i guess
you've already answered it because you
said you're putting them inside the cell
so what what are you trying to sense
inside the cell if it gets uh
sick or if it's stressed or if it's
happy absolutely
you're spot on so i i want to give a
shout out to you to the communities who
are
they are trying to put miniaturized
physical sensors inside of cells
um so they look like nano machines or
all kinds of great and interesting
things and that maybe falls more
under the biotic abiotic interfacing
research at the cellular level
now for us we're engineering proteins
for example
to measure small molecules in a cell's
environment
or you can imagine measuring the stress
state of a cell
and one place where this matters is
imagine that you have a company
and you're growing vats of bacteria
that you've engineered to make a small
molecule product or a medicine
and so you might want to know because
you had a lot of money
tied up in that bat and you know as we
know
biology can do strange things sometimes
for
on you know inexplicable reasons
um because we don't understand it well
enough yet so you might want to have
sensors built in so that
you know if you have a physical sensor
outside of the cell
you might just know that maybe the ph is
off or
your the yield of your product has
changed in a way that
you're unhappy with but imagine having a
sensor in each cell
in fact imagine having that control loop
in each cell so that
when they yield output from that cell
does something you don't like
that actuator in that control loop then
kicks that cell into be
becoming a high producer again so that
you can maximize your profits
and then fund more you know fund more
research with your problems
so that is bringing it closer to this
true goal of engineering rather than
just sort of building an individual cell
putting it to work in more specific ways
you know you can think of biology as one
of the most
advanced manufacturing platforms that we
can imagine
and there's a place of course for you
know
industry the way that we built it up up
until now
but imagine if we could grow our
products the same way we grow corn
or imagine instead of you know a 3d
printer that uses melted plastic in your
house you have something that looks more
like a bread maker and you actually grow
the products
there are lots of visions here um
and i think that you know we don't know
yet what it's going to look like
presumably uh well so for one thing i
want to get on the
table that as far as you know no one is
putting 5g
sense uh networks into uh vaccines or
anything like that right
because it sounds very close
no no no one is and um you know
the the vaccines the way they are now
are just such a marvel
of of biotechnology um
it's it's almost you know i'm almost
like personally offended
that you're almost minimizing this
achievement by saying that
not you but one you know people the
conspiracy theorists yeah
um but at the same time there's
absolutely nothing wrong with
questioning technology
you know if you don't question if you
don't feel like you can ask then how
will you learn
but i presume that fighting disease
would be an obvious target for these
uh engineered cells
absolutely so there are cellular
therapies out there already
you have car t therapies and um
this idea so i want to be clear here
that
the idea of control is important
because that in one important way
because
that leads to safety
so if you know you have a
well-controlled cell
now you can be more confident about
selling a cellular product
and you can be more confident that every
cell
that you sell to someone
is going to behave in exactly the way
you've programmed
so that you're actually curing someone's
cancer instead of giving them cancer
right kind of important yes
you know and we're used to again i'm
going to go back to an airplane we're
used to stepping on airplanes
and being confident that we're going to
arrive safely
and i would love it
if we could get to the point where we
don't even think about
cellular engineering or engineering
biology as separate from just
engineering because it's so predictable
it's so reliable so robust it's so
safe and it's such an integral part of
making people's lives
better because that's what we're after
at the end of the day
well for as a good example of that um
quite a while back i heard a famous
scientist uh speculate about the
possibility that we would be able to
engineer cells
monocellular organisms that would we
could release into the atmosphere
and they would eat up co2 to help solve
global warming or something like that
now obviously there is a problem with
the runaway you don't want to get away
with all the co2 in the atmosphere but
is it beyond diseases in our bodies is
that kind of
large-scale engineering something that
we could imagine
is part of the future of cellular
engineering
i think people are imagining that and um
you know there are people out there
thinking about how to best bring to bear
biotechnologies to any of the big
challenges we face
collectively um and climate change is of
course one of them
food security is another reshoring our
supply chains is another and you don't
necessarily need to
release cells um
to get them to gobble up co2 for you
why not change our biomanufacturing
processes so that they are
carbon neutral or carbon negative you
know up until now we've
very much been limited by energy we've
been worried about how much energy does
it take to manufacture something but
what if we switched our thinking and
thought instead about well how much
carbon you know what's the carbon budget
of my manufacturing process
um people are engineering plants or
trying to figure out better ways of
growing plants so that they lock more
co2
for example in bigger root structures
and so over time you're sequestering
worse
um there there are a lot of ways to
think about doing this that don't
necessarily go straight to
just blanket the flank of the globe in
it okay
and the other uh potential application
that i've heard a little bit about which
i wanted you to comment on
is building either little robots or
computers
out of either dna or cells and
uh you know i have my own questions
about this but maybe i'll let you say is
is that one of the things that you can
imagine we're going to be pursuing
i i think that the idea
is one that is
worthwhile i don't know that it's going
to look like
computers that we have already i mean
silicon is very good at what it does
but biology is not silicon and
one of the things my lab is working on
um is
you know we were building these sensors
but then how do we
process that information from the sensor
so up until now a lot of folks have been
working on boolean logic
inside of cells so that's very similar
to the kinds of logic that
your computer is doing but there are
other ways
that we know to make computers
think air quotes again um what if we
could
put a different kind of information
processing inside of cells
maybe we could so for example there are
folks who
use dna strand displacement circuits
to make neural network like computations
could we put that inside of living cells
maybe we wouldn't use dna maybe we would
use a different kind of biomolecule
you know so there are different ways of
of um thinking about how to put
information processing inside of cells
and you know the cells are doing it all
the time
so you know maybe maybe we should start
instead of
instead of by trying to you know jam
computers into
cells maybe we should just you know
invite this cell to t and say
sell you know tell me about yourself
like how are you processing information
you know and this is this goes back
historically to
um this rift between physics and biology
you know when i was a young scientist
the physicists were great at going up to
biologists and saying we're here to
solve it for you
well that's no way to make friends no no
so i think what we're seeing now is
people coming together and
taking a moment to really learn what the
other knows
see the value in it and try to put
together the quantitative approaches
from
physics and engineering with um
the incredible descriptive knowledge
um that we find in biology well and
something that
one of the reasons why i was questioning
this particular goal
is because as a physicist uh i'm
impressed by the fact that the
environment inside a cell is so very
very different than the environment that
we have
in our daily lives or in a computer
right uh
the thermal motions of molecules are
huge compared to
other things that are going on it's a
very noisy
uh hard to be predictable environment
does that get in the way of trying to
build computer-like things on those
scales
um you know i prefer to think of it as a
feature instead of a bug
so i think you have to be willing to to
see it not as a liability but as an
asset so in a previous life
i built i built small nanofloatic
staircases
and crammed long dna molecules um in
very tight confinement at the top of the
staircase
and they would walk basically they would
jiggle around
in this environment and they would
entropal for wreaths so there's an
entropy gradient for the dna molecule in
this
staircase and they would come out and we
were thinking about well who cares about
this
it's kind of a cool widget i suppose so
it's like a it's like a slinky
going down the staircase nano slinky
okay good
um and when i came to engineering
biology
i never really lost um
lost that vision of molecules
moving in ways that seem controlled but
are driven by random processes
right right and so how how is
biology how are biological systems
arranging themselves such that they're
taking full advantage of the biophysics
or just the physics you know the
thermodynamics of what's happening
in their system because you know if i
were a cell
i would probably be lazy you know i
wouldn't want to use more energy than i
would need and so i would want to
harness
everything that you know is just going
to happen naturally
with minimal effort so when i think
about minimal life and i know that uh
jeremy england has also talked a lot
about this
um so how would i harness the kind of
gradients the various gradients that i'm
experiencing anyway
and then only modify those that are
worth it to me because they give me some
fitness advantage
and in some sense this is a place where
the relationship between
energy and information comes to light
right
even i've written papers about this this
is very a frontier right now of
statistical physics non-equilibrium
dynamics
there is some sense in which biological
organisms
use information to do work right to make
things
happen and i've always been curious and
i have no strong opinions about
when that happens like at what point do
you say oh this is using information
rather than this is just rolling down a
hill in a sort of a mindless way
do you do you know the answer to that or
do you have opinions about it
i i love talking about the stuff
again i defer to the experts um i would
love
to sit down and think about different
experiments
you know as we think about our
capabilities with putting together
engineered systems whether we might use
an element of
nanotechnology in our experimental
design you know a little biology
whatever pieces you want to put together
to control
the system in a way that you're able to
ask and answer very cleanly
some of these questions that you're
posing um i think
you know we just need to find the right
people who who have the right friends
right with all of these expertise
together um
i don't know yet what those experiments
would look like but i think they're
coming
sounds like a good topic for a workshop
at the santa fe institute i might have
to
propose something like this science sign
me up all right
very very good um and so the the last
sort of topic i wanted to
talk about unless you you want to put
others on the table is um we've been
talking about cells
the whole time but in fact i get the
impression that a
fraction of your research is on the idea
of cell-free
synthetic biology like break out of the
boundaries
of the cellular membrane and but still
do biology so what is that even all
about
great question so i mentioned earlier
that you can consider
life on a spectrum so if you have a
spectrum with chemistry on one end
and you know a full blown naturally
evolved let's say mammalian cell
on the other end a human cell like
there's a lot of space in the middle
and um so if we kind of walk along that
spectrum
we might find you know we could go from
chemistry to
something called a pure system where
people have reconstituted certain
molecules
and you can get protein expression um if
you walk a little further
there are folks who grind up cells or
mush them up and get rid of all the
spatial organization
and just keep the components in a tube
and
can express proteins or do other things
with that so it can still
do biology even though you've smushed
its organization into smithereens
for example then you can keep walking
down that spectrum and you can come to a
minimal cell and you know
et cetera et cetera but to stop at the
cell free
system um it's such a bad name
but there it is sometimes they're called
cell free expression systems or
transcription translation systems these
are all you know
words to go google txtl systems
what's really nice about them is they
allow you to use the machinery of
biology
without that system needing to be alive
and so for example if you're making a
product you don't need to figure out how
to transport that product
outside of the cell across the membrane
to then go you know
separate it out and sell it to something
you can start thinking about
um doing chemistries that would be
lethal to a cell and
the cell free system might not care the
whole system is open and so you can
literally just stick your pipettor in
and put more of whatever you want into
it
um more energy more
you know more molecules to more
precursors or whatever you want
you can just just stick it in
um and so people are using cell free
systems as a biomanufacturing platform
for these reasons
another way people are using cell free
systems
is as a stop along the design build test
learn cycle
um it's a workflow in biology and
if you're engineering biology that's one
way to think about your workflow
and so i might start by saying well i
want a cell that does
x you know function x so i'm going to
design the dna
i'm going to order it from the dna store
it's going to come to me i'm going to
assemble it
and i'm going to put it into a cell for
example i might put on a plasmid
and um subject my cell to a high voltage
such that the membrane breaks down
partially and the dna goes in
i might electrocurate and then and then
you know let's see if we get function x
well very often
you don't and so what went wrong and in
the meantime you've been going through
this
workflow where you've been waiting for
cells to grow that takes
time it's it's much faster if you can
take an intermediate stop and use a cell
free system
to just quickly test your dna because it
doesn't have to grow
like you've got your cell boot in your
you know your minus 80 freezer
just pull some of that out that you've
made previously right
put your dna in and say well you know
does it glow
or you know do do i can i do a test that
will tell me that i can be reasonably
certain this is going to work in vivo
if i test it out first and
uh so the idea is that it would make
your
your workflow faster because you're not
needing to do everything in cells
now we uh just like for cells
we don't have a great understanding of
everything that is in that cell free
system often especially if it's
lysate-based
um you know if you're making it from the
guts of real cells
um people are working on it we do have
some some good models
but there's room for improvement
and um yeah and
this makes me think about once again
this origin of life question
um you know typically when i wrote in my
book the big picture about the origin of
life i i repeated what i was told which
is that you need
compartmentalization uh reproduction and
metabolism
to qualify for life and
compartmentalization always seemed like
the odd one
out there right um i mean i can see what
the advantages are but the necessity
was a little bit more obscure is it if
following what you said at the beginning
of the podcast that we should be
open-minded about other kinds of life
could we imagine that if we go to other
planets life does not happen in
cells but it's just more of a continuum
that sort of uh
smooshes together in interesting ways i
i think that's a wonderful thing to
think about
um you know some folks think that life
might have arisen
in rocks where there are very small
chambers
i i think there's also a lot of room in
engineering biology for figuring out how
to put back
in engineered compartmentalization or
you know ways where you can gather up
molecules of interest
in closer proximity so that they react
in ways that are more advantageous
for you you know and that might look
like some of the really interesting
liquid liquid phase transition work
that folks have been doing um inside of
cells
you know other folks are using
microfluidic and nanofluidic chips
where you have these very small channels
in say glass or silicon where you're
confining
biomolecules maybe a cell free system
and
looking at how those behave under under
this engineered confinement
um also spreading it out on chip gives
you an easy way to image so to measure
what's happening
um so i think there are different ways
people
um are going about influencing
or or engineering back in
something like cellular confinement or
nanoscale confinement
so uh i mean there's too many good
things that you dropped in there in
terms of um
questions we don't yet know the answer
to i remember once uh
i told this story before so maybe it
appeared on the podcast but
um i invited a biologist bonnie basler
from princeton to come to give the
physics colloquium at caltech
and she was talking about bacteria and
quorum sensing
and uh my graduate students afterward
were just shaking their heads with like
it's so easy to find questions we don't
know the answer to in biology
but we can do experiments to try to
answer like in particle physics as you
know
it's just harder right it's a it's a
more mature field so i'm very excited
about the
the frontiers that you're working on
it's a great time to be in this field
um i do want to mention that you know as
a physicist um i
very much grew up in the shadow of um
some of the physics greats who were
involved in
um bringing about the nuclear age right
this is the cautionary tale that we are
all
you know we're all taught and i'm hoping
i'm very optimistic that
synthetic biologists engineering
biologists will
learn from history and think long and
hard
not just about what we could do but what
we should do
and the stakes are so high for us we
have to build trust
um if we're going to arrive at a future
where we can all thrive
i remember there's another story that
i've often told um i i do
science consulting for hollywood and my
wife jennifer was uh
the director of a consulting
organization and she
set up for a movie a bunch of scientists
and that were tasked with you know if he
wanted to build a
terrible plague you know a viral plague
that would kill a lot of people what
would we do
and the scientists came together they
came out going like oh we could totally
do this
and it is you know i think physics has
sort of
passed that threshold where the research
that is going on
in fundamental physics now higgs bosons
or
dark matter or string theory or whatever
is not in any danger
of uh being weaponized in any moment and
that baton has been passed to
fundamental biology where the number of
things that could happen
uh is pretty scary but i always like to
end the podcast on optimistic note so
give us your most optimistic reading of
how the future is going to become
better because of synthetic biology and
engineering biology
my hope is that our ability
to apply biotechnologies to make
people's lives better
then you know it might look like new
kinds of therapeutics
and we've already seen it in new kinds
of vaccines and cellular
therapies um i'm hoping that it gives
more people more access to ways of
making things
so um you might have heard of the biofab
movements no um where
so um if you have like maker labs
where people have a lot of tools for
working with
plastics and metal electronics well
extend that to
biological systems as well yeah um
and you know at the end of the day we're
biological
and it's so important for us to make
sure that everybody
has access to
what we need to keep ourselves healthy
and happy
clean air clean water healthy
new nutritious food
that there's so much upside to
biotechnologies here again i think that
we're limited by
our um our imaginations
and then after that how do we want to
prioritize
what we could do well it's clearly so
that it works for everyone
yeah i mean things are happening very
very rapidly it's fun to look at the
progress
in real time and it is important as you
emphasize to at the same time
take a step back and and think carefully
about whether we're doing the right
thing as we're doing all these
fun things so elizabeth strzhalski
thanks so much for being on the blind
skate podcast
thank you it's been great fun
[Music]
you